[Music]  [Music]  cuz of Jews bring me I'll never welcome  to new homes big number you're rolling  let's give him a great show okay what  why do they want an angry gorilla anyway  your silverback be terrified humans  [Music]  terrifying my sister where's your sister  now  remember  memories never leave us they just get  out of reach javis a gorilla who draws  what is it  don't tell me don't tell me it's a  lonely a stack on a late summer day it's  a beetle tell me story once there was a  baby elephant that was smart and brave  and she needed to live in the wild where  she could be free  [Music]  it's the baby and I ain't get to be free  [Music]  this painting is clearly a sign he wants  to be free  about Mac you stick give me my whole  life  family bring this together  [Music]  I'll just cost throw them why would you  cross the road to get to the other side  [Music]